hi guys I recently went to London calm
calm this is not the first time I've
been to London comic-con however this is
the first time i have been a presenter
at london comic-con hi I'm yag Mannix
but today I am Maxum where there are
things are and I'm with Kai creative
we're about to go into London comic-con
to see what awesome characters they can
find so let's come inside
Oh
he's been she told me if I'm rubbish
it's not my fault
how are you finding comic-con of you
having a good day yeah absolutely i'll
say i've been coming for a long time now
this suit I've had for a couple years
it's it's last call as well because I do
have a mark 43 being built for me so yet
that will be for 2016 I did notice your
suits a bit battered and bruised I
thought maybe you'd been fight I've been
in a few fights yeah there's been a few
DC that quite not like us marble people
so let's defend off a couple of those
guys so yeah a couple of scratches but
you should see the other guys I have no
doubt that you won those buckles
thank you very much hi created got in
touch with me he's an amazing
videographer and he asked me to be an
interview estas presenter personality to
interview all the cosplayers at
comic-con and I have to say it was such
a fun experience I went there and I'm
not gonna lie I was so scared to go up
to these really awesome cosplayers and
just say hey can I ask you some
questions but I did it and it works out
really well actually he's putting videos
together and you can see the phone
interview here but as were my
experiences I had an amazing time most
where it's getting bigger and bigger
every single year the people are amazing
some of them have spent months and
months or years and years on the outfit
and it's so easy to see there was a
woody popping out of a pizza box there
was a real Iron Man with everything
lighting up and there's people there
using our drina's and raspberry pies and
little things like that to make the most
awesome creations by an arduino kit on
for 20 quid off ebay and then make stuff
get creative I teach art students for a
living and how to do electronic so we
teach them how to make interactive art
work start with getting sensor
controlling a motor and then build up
there's like a plant that grows and the
lights happened we don't have one year
where when you whistle the clock comes
off smoke and then shoes if you step
then they would take out if you ran in
them they were stopped swearing at you
calling words contraptions look facebook
when i get home that will happen photos
will go up and then i'll try and post
some stuff if you ever get a chance good
comic con you need to go do not forget
to check out the full interview video
over on his channel it's amazing he did
an awesome job of video and editing it
was a pleasure to present for him let me
know in the comments below if you were
at comic-con and also if you were did
you dress up and if you weren't would
you dress up here would you yourself as
so many questions
want to do it do it anyway I hope you
enjoyed this video and have a lovely
evening